[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence au tout
avec le sommaire de ce numéro le mois de
décembre a débuté et avec lui les
marchés de noël nous parlerons de celui
de la ferme du manet de montigny le
bretonneux près de 130 exposants sont
attendus ce week-end au prisme la
comédienne flore lefebvre des noëttes
raconte son histoire celle d'une famille
de 13 enfants dans les années 60
découverte dans ce magazine
enfin le rendez vous dédié aux juniors
mélanie nous présentera les cabanes à
lire installé à saint 30 enfants moomin
pour la fête du conte
tout d'abord ce week-end c'est la 30e
édition du téléthon sur tout le
territoire comme chaque année de
nombreux rendez vous sont organisés au
profit de la recherche médicale les
yvelines 2 n'y font pas exception et
pour les plus sportifs le club de roller
hockey tu d'elancourt organise sa
traditionnelle disco roller ce dimanche
à 14h les profits seront reversés à
l'afm téléthon
on écoute le vice président du club nous
parler de cette journée une patine on
patine en musique avec des animations
diverses animations de type course de
type un petit peu de danse de ce genre
de choses
et cette année on a en plus un défi
téléthon
donc qui est en fait un défi marathon où
on va essayer d'atteindre les 42 ouverte
du 2 km sur les quatre heures de la
discorde
avis aux nostalgiques des flippers ou
des baby foots voici une exposition qui
pourrait vous plaire adresse force au
rapidité ces jeux des années 40 à 90 ont
eu leur heure de gloire dans les salles
de jeu ou sur les fêtes foraines
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois permet de les découvrir
ou les redécouvrir jusqu'au 11 décembre
le commissaire de l'exposition nous en
dit un mot plat vous allez vous allez
voir au fil de l'expo des jeux qui sont
plus plutôt en bois années 40
et puis plus plus plus les années
passent plus la technologie avance et
vous allez d'avoir des flippers jusqu'en
1990 on a tous joué un moment donné dans
sa jeunesse au bar principalement
puisque les flippers était
essentiellement à une époque dans les
bistrots on ne voulait pas d'expo musée
où vous voulez des expo interactive où
les gens puissent découvrir l'histoire
du jeux forains du jeu ou de bistrot
mais également jouer on peut pas parler
du jeu sans jouer
les premières cases du calendrier de
l'avent ont été ouvertes jeudi 1er
décembre le mois de décembre c'est bien
sûr noël et ce week-end montigny le
bretonneux organise son marché de noël à
la ferme du manet marie tout ça en
charge et événementiel à la mairie de
montigny le bretonneux nous a rejoint en
plateau bonjour marie bonjour alors un
petit mot sur ce marché de noël à la fin
du madness est un rendez vous
immanquable il existe depuis 25 ans
combien d'exposants est ce qu'on
retrouve cette année qu'est ce qu'il y
aura donc cette année nous avons près de
130 exposants
soixante quinze artisans à l'intérieur
de la grange et 54 alimentaire à
l'extérieur dans la cour
camille angers on vous l'avait dit
justement ce marché de noël il est
scindé un petit peu en deux parties
qu'elles produisent ce qu'on peut
retrouver dans l'artisanat
alors au niveau alimentaire on a toutes
les régions de france qui sont
représentés
donc pour les papilles de la bouche pour
le pour le réveillon pour les fêtes de
noël
nous avons du vin de toutes les régions
de france
nous avons un champagne avec modération
nous avons beaucoup de foie gras huit
exposants de foie gras cassoulet donc
des régions qu'il faut qu'ils font
saliver
nous avons également du miel des
artisans de miel nous avons des
biscuiteries vous savez aussi à
l'extérieur on a des produits locaux
également effectivement donc cette année
nous avons 3 3 signé mon teint qui sont
présents sur sur le marché alimentaire
on à banana hills un artisan antillais
donc avec ces produits antillais
nous savons dans angèle hic la
boulangerie du mané qui présente avec
ses différentes 1
c'est effectivement nous avons des
macarons les montagnes vous propose
également des animations pour les
enfants avec quelques nouveautés cette
année
alors cette année nous avons une
nouveauté qui est la grande roue de 16
mètres de haut avec 8 nacelle et 32 32
personnes maximum
la nouveauté aussi pour cette année sur
cette grande roue c'est que le donc
c'est un euro vers personnes et 7 euros
cet argent qui sera il sera donné à la
fm pour le téléthon il est important de
participer à cette grande cause
donc le marché de noël a débuté
justement ce matin et également sous
l'égide de l'été du téléthon pardon vous
le disiez pour ce week-end comment ça
s'est passé à l'installation si vous
avez déjà eu un petit peu de monde ce
vendredi 2 décembre nous avons il ya
énormément de monde qui sont
principalement des habitués qui ont
passé commande pour la plupart du temps
qui viennent acheter des produits
principalement alimentaires et qui
viennent de très loin ce matin des
personnes qui venaient du sud et de
l'essonne vous nous avons aussi nous
allons bénéficier probablement de
nouvelles personnes qui sont qui vont
venir suite à la fermeture de marché
noël aux alentours du à la sécurité qui
n'ont pas pu mettre en place
contrairement à nous montrent unis on a
pu assurer cette sécurité
on a parlé un petit peu de l'alimentaire
et mais du côté avec le foie gras
notamment le vin etc
mais côté artisanat qu'est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver comme
des bijoux peut-être ce genre de choses
tout à fait donc sur les soixante quinze
artisans qui seront présents à
l'intérieur de la flamme du mal et dans
la grange nous avons trente sept
nouveautés ce qui permet à chacun d'être
d'entre vous d'entre nous de découvrir
de nouvelles nouveautés qui sont les
bijoux qui sont leurs céramiques l'art
floral des produits pour décorer les
noëls les tables de noël des cartes de
voeux 36 nouveaux exposants cette année
également ça l'amène à 130 exposants
s'affairent pour pas mal de monde
et du coup l'idée c'est vraiment de
trouver des idées pour se faire plaisir
et faire plaisir à ses proches pour noël
tout à fait donc nous avons les papiers
et puis nous avons c'est le plaisir
d'avoir des cadeaux au pied du sapin
bompas super merci beaucoup marie est
revenue dans le 7-8 loisirs nous parler
de ce marché de noël
l'un des premiers dans les villes
alentours avec celui de bois d'arcy ce
week-end également à ne pas manquer
merci encore et avant de refermer cette
page consacrée à noël on prend la
direction d'eads en cours jeudi soir la
ville donnait le top départ des
festivités en lançant les illuminations
ici à la clé saint pierre un igloo
illuminé a été installé pour le plus
grand bonheur des enfants peut le voir
sur ces images les illuminations
resteront tout le temps des fêtes
toujours à l encours mais au prisme
cette fois flore lefebvre des noëttes
écrivain et comédienne mais sa vie en
scène un retour sur son histoire celle
d'une famille nombreuse catholique dans
les années 60
nous avons rencontré l'artiste lors
d'une répétition et l'analyser
la figure maternelle une source
d'inspiration pour flore lefebvre des
noëttes à la mort de sa mère il ya
quatre ans elle a pris la plume pour
raconter son histoire
c'est plutôt un hommage autour de tout
la figure merveilleuse de ma maman qui
était une espèce de mère courage des
années 60 et qui nous a élevés les
traits enfants étaient très à la maison
malgré un père qui était défaillant et
qui était qui était malade tout le temps
malgré la difficulté les difficultés la
maladie et terra la cette famille
nombreuse c'est une vitalité
extraordinaire et donc c'est un hommage
à la vie
flores interprète seuls les 30
personnages qui rythme la pièce ponctuée
d'une bande sonore typiquement années 60
pendant une heure la comédienne embarque
le spectateur au coeur de son enfance en
mêlant tragique et
[Musique]
je force un peu le trait de caractère de
chaque personnage et comme le pat mon
papa était foule ça crée des choses
assez rigolote complètement décalé et
puis la natte donc la maman elle était
aussi très autoritaire cheftaine donc ça
fait plein de caractère très haut en
couleur et c'est vraiment commis quoi du
début jusqu'à la fin
avec une écriture teinté de proust ou
balzac au temps des trente glorieuses
les rires les peurs et l'énergie de la
meute de la matte prennent vie sur la
chaîne du prisme
j'ai fort
l'avant dans l'autre
et je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière avec notre invité la fête du
conte à débarquer dans les médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines pour une
seizième édition
mélanie poker notre chroniqueuse juniors
nous a rejoint pour nous parler d'un
dispositif un peu particulier bonjour
camille alors si c'est une première pour
saint quentin en yvelines pour les
habitués vous les avez peut-être déjà
remarqué des petites tentes ont investi
les lieux de lecture quand on pénètre à
l'intérieur on y trouve des livres bien
sûr et des petits coussins pour
s'installer tranquillement ses petites
cabanes sont prêtés par la bibliothèque
du chéné juliette garcia bibliothécaire
à la médiathèque anatole france situé à
trappes nous en explique le principe
l'idée c'est de créer un petit coin un
peu intime pour découvrir des histoires
donc on a préparé des petits paniers
thématiques qu'on met à l'entrée de la
cabane et les enfants et pourquoi pas
leurs parents ont plaisir à rentrer dans
cette cabane à découvrir les livres
conduit à vous ou à venir avec d'autres
livres et s'installer alors justement
derrière juliette on a pu apercevoir la
cabane elle semble parler de la peur
bien trouvé c'est exactement ça et comme
la masquer la mascotte de cette fête du
compte c'est le loup le thème pour cette
fois était tout trouvé mais il y en a
d'autres il ya la nature il ya le
fantastique et même la gourmandise
l'ensemble de la cabane est modifié et
les couleurs changent en fonction du
thème la cabane nature vous n'avez pas
un rideau noir mais un rideau vert avec
des petites feuilles des animaux des
arbres de différent à nous lasser la
cabane qui fait peur donc on a le loup
la chauve souris le fantôme gras cabane
gourmandise on peut imaginer que des
choses dont on se régale et les livres à
découvrir sont également sur ses thèmes
et ses cabanes mon peut y entrer jusqu'à
quand on peut les découvrir jusqu'au 10
décembre
trois médiathèques les proposent à
datant de france dont 4 ap
celle du canal à montigny le bretonneux
car ouvert il ya peu de temps le 16
novembre et antoine de saint-exupéry un
texte péri à voisins le bretonneux et
pourquoi pas le refaire chez soi on peut
choisir un petit coin dans sa chambre ou
dans la maison dans la maison
nous n'accordons pas des parents quand
même un drap donné c'est ça peut servir
aussi quelques coussins et puis le tour
est joué
il ne reste plus qu'à se laisser porter
par le comte merci beaucoup mélanie de
nous avoir présenté ce dispositif les
cabanons le rappelle sont en accès libre
au public mais aux heures d'ouvertures
des médiathèques ne vous faites pas
avoir
on passe maintenant à notre agenda la 7e
édition du salon des arts de plaisir
débute ce week ends jusqu'au 11 décembre
avec cette année une invitée d'honneur
la sculpteuse nathalie cas - chaney de
nombreux artistes sont à découvrir dans
la salle
armande béjart à maurepas humour mime et
clown rial à l'espace albert camus
l'artiste patrick cottet-moine sera en
représentation demain pour un spectacle
complètement décalé et on se quitte
d'ailleurs sur un extrait je vous laisse
juge
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end quoi
[Musique]